okay what up guys what uh i always get
complaints
about me starting late so today i
started my my live show
two minutes early
so hello guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome
to
my call-in show where i encourage people
to disagree with me before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
so
i know i promised a friday night call-in
show
but but but
this is what sorry this is what i
realized okay
i don't want to stream every day okay i
get tired
so
i'm gonna do the post game
and this is after the pre-game show
where you guys can call me and disagree
with me
about what i talked about
on the pregame or about another topic
now i know you guys hate this i know you
do
but it's women only
i know i know
but
one of these days i will do men too
but
that day is not today
it's really not
so
what have i said that you disagree with
let me know in the chat what is what is
the most
controversial thing that i have said
i've said a lot oh wait let me make sure
my sound is working in hindsight
um you know sometimes
okay yeah it is okay
what have i said that's controversial
what if you identify as a woman that
doesn't count
we live in reality over here at the just
pearly things youtube channel
so a couple things that i've said over
the couple of years
a couple of months that i've been doing
this show
i won't be drinking
any caffeine this late
so
what have i said that people disagree
with so a lot of people have a problem
with me yesterday i went out and i was
talking about abortion
and a lot of people just couldn't
get
over the fact that me as a woman i don't
agree
with abortion
i had someone i had a man try to argue
with me
i had a man try to argue with me and say
that
because sometimes humans make irrational
decisions and he cited
um
forgot what the economic theory he cited
i really forgot what the economic theory
that he cited was but there's some
economic theory that he cited that went
that people don't make rational
decisions all the time so
if people don't make rational decisions
then
shouldn't
shouldn't we have a fail safe and i said
if people don't make rational decisions
then shouldn't they have to fix the
consequences for those decisions anyways
my point is
i've said a lot of controversial things
leave the whales
a woman is a woman a biological woman is
a woman
you disagree with these goddamn women
only shows well lazy artist
you know what if
it may it may it may expand to the men
if i can't get some women on here
okay someone said
let's see
um
let's see
also i have a couple rules if you want
to call in
your camera's gotta be on
the reason is we don't do trolls here
i don't i don't need y'all trolling and
some of you guys come for my looks okay
rude right rude but if you're going to
come for my looks i want to see what you
look like
i want to see what you look like
um
adam and i
the
i will explain that not on this stream
because people aren't going to see the
context and if i explain it
like i i
you need to hear what he said anyways if
you dm me i'll explain that but
you identify as a woman to call in
not anyways so my point is guys i don't
need you guys to like
come in
i have been i've been running thank you
thank you sorry i'm letting you guys gas
me up i can't do that no simping no
simping
no simping
none keep it out of the comments section
keep it out of the cup guys
no sim behavior okay you disagree that
men can exercise their options i make
over six figures and you won't cheat
period my money doesn't give me the
right to cheat or any man for a matter
of that fact i agree with you i don't
agree with cheating i know i had a show
called let your man cheat
i know i did that that is a hundred
percent true i absolutely did that show
i was
look it
all i wanted
was it was a clickbait but i'll tell you
like the title but if you actually
listen to the episode i don't think it
gives you the right to cheat but my
problem is when girls go after guys like
say
jason derulo
and you're shocked when he cheated on
you an international
whatever his
boo thing's name is
like man what did you expect
so
yeah that's that's where i'm at with
that one
dale what did i say i said women
why are you guys calling in this is a
women call-in show i said women
i said women do you guys look like women
yeah
i'm sorry
okay
look i may i may open it up in a little
bit i'm gonna give
i'm gonna give people like
20 minutes
before i let the men in if we go live
for 20 minutes and no women call in i'll
let the men in
i'm sorry guys i i feel like my calling
is to talk to women i'm really trying to
talk to women
that's what i'm trying to do
um you've never felt the need for more
than one woman a lot of guys don't i'm
there's you know high value guys that
make six figures that don't want to do
that
my point is that
i just don't i'm just not into feeling
bad for ourselves
um
that one lady on your show today was
nuts which lady let me know
my audience is 85 men thank you very
much
15 women what i need you guys to do
is send this to your feminist send this
stream
to your feminist friends
modern friends
who would hate me
send this stream to them
send it also guys
i'm i'm doing subscribers only mode
at the moment because i'm so tired of
you watching [ __ ] for free
i'm so tired it's a subscribe is free
can you ask a question through the chat
yeah you can
what are what are some of my
controversial takes
i have a lot
hold on let me let me move this down a
little bit okay
i like this better
so for anybody that i was wondering
anyone that's wondering
anybody that is wondering
i'm gonna put we are doing a call-in
show
for the women okay women only
so
i want to talk to women that disagree
with me
now i know a lot of you women will call
in and be like i love you but i disagree
and then not really disagree
i don't want to talk to you guys i'm
sorry i don't
i want to talk to send me your women
it is a saturday night
i know y'all got hoes
send it
hi pearl how is it that you're based in
the uk when you're raised in the u.s
well i moved here sir
um i'm gonna put the the call in in the
chat
leave the whales don't date baby mamas
if you get pregnant it's your own fault
i do think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault
look it
swear to god i swear to god if i
if i ever get pregnant it is my own
fault
the 304s are out getting drunk
what is it 7 30 eastern 2 30 wait no no
i feel backwards
9 30 eastern
i know this might be a little too early
for 304s but i'm going to be sleeping
soon
i should reach out
directly to feminists
what the sir
i gotta don't make me ban you from the
studio stop coming in here
so another thing let's let's talk about
the issue that i have is modern women
okay
now let's be honest i'm a modern woman
everyone born in the west is a modern
woman but when i'm talking about the
modern woman i'm talking about the ones
i don't need a man
okay
let's let's not hold women accountable
for anything they can't do anything
wrong
i don't need a man type [ __ ]
i'm a strong independent woman boss babe
because here's the thing guys we need
men
and i'm gonna i'm gonna just speak to
the women now we need men to exist
if
all the men disappeared off the planet
today
we would be screwed none of us know how
to do [ __ ]
i don't know how to fix my car i don't
have a car actually anymore but if i did
i wouldn't know how to fix it
and the men are tired and i've been
listening to men for the past year okay
just listen to them talk i'm gonna tell
you what they're tired of i'm gonna be
putting you guys on game
okay
they're tired of not feeling needed and
they're tired of women that offer
nothing but sex and good looks
they're also tired
of
women
that are sleeping with everybody and
then demanding a ring
how you gonna ask for a ring
have you banged the whole football team
diane
okay zoe what is up
i need you to turn on your camera let's
see we got someone
uh private chat can i be anonymous
what do you should let me know in the
chat should i let should i let her be
anonymous i feel like if you're gonna
come on you should show your face to be
honest
mostly because
i don't need trolls on here and this
just is a lot of trolls that way
would i ever sign a prenup i would
yeah
i got a veto oh she she left anyway so i
was like i gotta veto this anyway
okay we got five more minutes till i let
the men in
fine
fine
also in order to be a part of the chat
you have to have subscribed for 10
minutes
i'm tired of this nonsense
and that's the other thing modern women
are always moving the goal post
always
always every show let's talk about the
show tonight
it's like we should agree on this stuff
fat people are less attractive it's not
fun this girl's thinner than me that
have better better banging bodies than
me
um i work every day i work out five days
a week y'all
i'm i'm still trying to lose weight i'm
still working towards it i still am but
the thing is if you don't admit there's
a problem how are you going to find the
solution and that's the problem with
women is we always talk about
we never talk about
the problem and we don't
it
say that the problem exists so then
therefore there is no solution
so
y'all i want you to send your women so
what are some of our problems we're
overweight we're disagreeable we don't
know how to be wives
we don't go for the guy we want and when
we find a guy that we like
we're not doing [ __ ] for him
so
that that's that's what i'm hearing from
the men
and i talked to the women too i'm not
i'm not saying the men are innocent
let's talk about what i hear from the
women
he's not a good leader i can't submit
um he's addicted to corn
and video games
so there's issues on both sides
i'm not saying it's just the women
but at least men when
when they got an issue they own up to it
i'll give you the example today if you
call a man broke
he'll go make money
or accept that he's not going to get any
girls but on the other hand if you tell
a girl
that she's fat hell has frozen over
i'm gonna move this here oh no oh no
oh no that's not good hold on guys oh no
okay wait
hold on y'all
okay back
back okay my bad i was moving the camera
more to the middle
do you expect do you all expect mariah
carey
and to buy food for nick cannon's kids
no
okay
bro i
look at we get tech issues
all right
i got 60 seconds before i'm letting the
men in fine
fine
fine
like the video y'all this better be at
200 likes a like is free
i'm not six two
i'm five eleven and a half thank you
most women here agree with you
i know
all right y'all fine men come in
men come in
i won't let women come i won't let men
come in without a face cam either like
y'all
okay so send the man
hello hey what's up can you hear me hold
on bro yeah i can hear you
yeah so i'm just gonna cut straight to
the chase uh yeah bro let me call you
back let me call you back
so i i just think the problem with it
with a lot of what's going on today is
people don't know the difference between
a boyfriend and a husband i think that's
the problem
in our society today
and if you don't know the difference
between a boyfriend and a husband
you're not going to know how to navigate
and you're not going to know how to
conduct yourself among people period
all right i would love to ask
all the women today you know like what
do you think the difference i would like
to ask you pearl
what do you think the difference is
between a boyfriend and a husband
well a boyfriend's someone who's gonna
invest in you long term
boyfriend a husband sorry husband i said
boyfriend
um
and i don't know i think there's certain
traits that husbands possess
that like it has to be a man that wants
to be a husband is the main thing
i think a lot of times girls are trying
to turn
guys that don't want to be husbands
okay but
yeah but as far as like
what do you think the inherent
differences are between a boyfriend and
a husband
that's a really good question
um i mean i think there's a lot of like
i i think i think a lot of the traits
that like my dad possesses that's what i
look for so like hard-working um
dependable responsible
um
yeah i would say those are like the main
traits hard-working
and i really i think it's important to
have a guy that
like also like wants to be committed
long-term i would say yeah
and so yeah and and like just how you
were thinking about it right now that's
the problem there isn't a clear
understanding of what that is and so a
lot of people
are coming out into the world
no infrastructure no understanding
and that that's what needs to change but
it's not going to change
because
that conversation is not happening
conversation that's happening today is
is he six two shut down that's a good
show topic actually i'm gonna write that
down
yeah that that that's that's what's
happened that's what's happening today
the conversation today is is he six two
does he have a huge wheat does he have
does he have a huge wiener
does he live in beverly hills
what type of car does he drive
you know that's the conversation it's
not a conversation between what's the
difference between a boy a boyfriend and
a husband
yeah i know what the other issue too is
can i say one more thing can i say one
more thing yeah go ahead
another issue about our society today
is people don't know the difference
between a sugar baby and a housewife
that's the other issue
okay swear to god
what do you think the difference is
between a sugar baby and a housewife
a sugar baby and a housewife well i
would say a sugar baby's just paid to be
there a housewife creates a home
so like when i think of a housewife i
think of like someone that creates
family traditions
and makes a house a home
and like ensues culture into the
children
and you think and you think nine out of
uh 10 girls would say the same thing you
just said or no
probably not
no probably not
and that's another issue
so what do you think what are you what's
your what i can tell you
i can tell you and this is something
i've had to learn the hard way
the difference between a boyfriend
and a husband
is a husband is somebody you're legally
involved with
okay a boyfriend you're not legally
involved with
do you think that someone can be
do you think that someone could be a
husband without getting the government
involved like where they yeah they're
doing the same things so then wouldn't
that kind of
discredit what you're saying okay so i'm
going to bring another point where this
is another part of the reason why our
society is [ __ ] up
people don't know the difference between
a marriage license
and a marriage contract
okay go on
and so this is and i'm about to really
bring the angel i'm going to be the
angel of the heaven today
so okay
a marriage contract
is an agreement between two people
okay husband and wife
a marriage license is a is an agreement
between husband wife and a state
yes yeah that's the difference but 99 of
people don't know that
i think most people know you have to get
the government involved to get married
let me ask your followers do you guys
know the difference between a marriage
contract and a marriage license
no
people don't know that
that conversation's not happening
publicly and so pearl so pearl this is
what's happening
there's a lot of women today
extremely beautiful extremely degreed
extremely accomplished extremely high iq
but they don't know how to operate
they don't know how to operate in our
system because there's a framework in
place feminism isn't a system
feminism is a philosophy
so that's what's happening
and so
first of all you need to know the
difference between a boyfriend and a
husband
you need you need to know the difference
between a sugar baby and a housewife
and then you need to know the difference
between a marriage contract and a
marriage license
and until you get those things
you won't know how to conduct yourself
with men period
and that's how it goes
so and i i can i can go into it
you know
a husband is somebody you're legally
involved with your boyfriend is somebody
you're socially involved with
sugar baby
and a housewife sugar baby is somebody
who you're financially involved with a
with a man you don't have children with
marriage contract two people marriage
license two people in state there you go
then you'll be able to operate out here
okay well
all right cool well thanks for calling
in no problem
have a good one yeah you do
okay
um
all right who we got
hello
what's up are you are you driving
i'm sorry i got a job i'm gonna pull
over real quick
you better pull over i i'm not i'm gonna
i'm gonna took you off the street stream
till you pull over because we can't this
is our goal okay all right hello
i just okay yeah i know um
hello
oh what's up i'm sorry i'm sorry how you
doing i'm good how are you
what's the uh topic
oh i said disagree with me
about
about what we want us to disagree about
i mean that's why
anything i've said i have hours and
hours of content
i'm just now you know learning about
your your page so you know
you should maybe watch it and then call
it again okay
one thing else
oh wait sorry i just kicked him so that
i was too late
i didn't mean to okay um other guys
still driving
i'm sorry you can click it again you can
click it again and come back i i clicked
kick
i meant to add you out of the stream
why are all these people driving
okay none of you have your cameras on
i'm just like he's like what is this
about i'm like what is the title
disagree with me about what i'm like
anything i've said okay
are you parked
hands up i need to say you're not
driving all right i'm not driving
okay what
what do you disagree with me on
so
the only thing i
disagree it's on your stream you say
that
people with children should date people
with children
yeah
leave outside of this
yeah i feel you
i feel you but
i want to disagree with that can i tell
you why yeah okay go ahead
because
the expectations
for uh
for for single moms and single dads are
different
okay i can tell you it's like
especially with people who
with uh single fathers that make
a good income they make a good living
and uh have custody of their children
so
when if i date if i date a woman without
children
she doesn't expect nor do i expect
for her to
buy mcdonald's for all four of my kids
i don't have four kids but
i know
that video went viral and you see the
difference
no man is gonna no man is gonna
criticize a woman
for bringing mcdonald's for one kid
as a matter of fact a man wouldn't
require her to bring mcdonald's for any
of those children
so
i i just want to i just want like
freshman like future
future
and
people
live in a
high standard of living like him
how many women
say i don't wanna date a future
because he has kids
no i mean look at
i i didn't say all girls feel like this
like men and women are different and a
single father and a single mother is
definitely completely different right
but i just think do you do do you have a
daughter
no
no i just think if i had a daughter
i would tell her to date a guy with no
kids before i tell him her to date
someone with kids
because it's just like yeah because it's
just like a lot of drama and it's just
something like if you could choose i
don't know why you would pick someone
with kids
and i think that's for both i think
that's for both sexes to be and i think
that in general people with kids should
just date each other but if a guy can
swing it then he doesn't have to date a
girl with kids do it
damn that's so easy
yeah like if you could swing it but i
just don't think
i i just wouldn't tell my little sister
to do that and i wouldn't do that myself
but would you tell her not to though
would you tell her yeah no i would tell
her not to i would just say that's drama
you don't need because it's like
you have to deal with the the ex-wife or
the ex or the baby mama it's just like
why would you deal with that drama when
you could deal with someone who doesn't
have that
understandable and i don't i don't know
what type of drama
you know honestly i feel like if if a
man has baby mama drama
then he's probably not
he's probably not very responsible
or um
he's not good at picking women
but uh
i think a man can i think a man can
defuse
and handle a situation with multiple
women better than a woman can handle a
situation with multiple men
because
a man
he should be a leader right
if if his baby mama respects him
because he's a great provider and
he pretty much he makes the rules
because he's just he's just that guy
mhm
if she respects him why isn't she why
isn't she he with her
like why doesn't he want that
i know but why
like is wouldn't you say a husband
someone that wants to keep the family
together
i agree i agree with it
and so it's like if he's gonna do that
to her why wouldn't he do that to you
and i don't know maybe she was doing
some wild [ __ ] you don't know but if she
was doing some wild [ __ ]
then like he's not good at picking women
so it's like a different
okay
well uh all right well i ain't trying to
beat a dead horse i just want to uh
i never heard anybody really challenge
you on that before
so um
i wanted to
um
okay well thanks for calling in yeah all
right dude bye okay bye
okay
um
let's see oh is that a girl
let's see
hello
hello
hi
i'm sorry your internet
your internet's so bad i
agree with um
i i can't hear you i'm so
okay wait let's
are you there
um hello
i'm here
can you hear me okay i'm
oops i can now okay
oh
can you hear me now
yes
yeah this keeps freezing
um okay
um
this this keeps freezing
um try to fix your try to fix your wi-fi
i'm gonna leave you in the back but
right now i'm also gonna kick people
whose cameras aren't on to leave room
for people who cameras are on
so
because if you don't have your camera on
i can't see you
uh i don't
yeah okay
um
hello
how are you doing
i'm good how are you
i'm all right just got back from outside
it's really hot
okay where are you at
i'm in new jersey
that was oh new jersey it's kind of mild
here in london so it's not that hot
nah new jersey's brutal
so um tell me what do you disagree with
me on
hmm that's a good question
what do i disagree with you on what why
did you why did you click the link
disagree with me hold on
i got one thing
now in regards to like you know
saying
in regards to like how some women
conduct themselves like the modern woman
i hear this
like some people say oh it's hard to
avoid them and stuff but i disagree with
that to an extent that is that it's hard
to avoid the modern woman and how to
avoid certain women i disagree with that
you don't think all women in the west
are modern
but if you're if you're raised in the
west it's tough not to like have any
societal impact right unless you're
going to like east asia you want real
you ever meet a real traditional woman
yeah okay
i've met a couple and like i said i
studied the word
so i used the word to guide me
i look proverbs probably is the wisdom
book it tells you how to avoid certain
women like proverbs one scripture i'll
quote it for you proverbs is um one
scripture says basically that a
beautiful woman who lacks discretion is
like a ring on a pig snout
okay
what does that tell you
i don't know
so basically that tells you don't always
go after her beauty
go after if she believes in the lord a
woman that holds the lord and upkeep her
house is the crown of life to her
husband
okay
so it makes a lot of sense when you like
go back to the bible
because that's like the start of
everything
it it talks to stuff like this it talks
about abortions and stuff it talks about
that's against the word
so what do you disagree with me on
because i don't
i know there's i i because when i think
of mod like the modern woman i think in
order to be traditional you have to be a
virgin like that's a true that's a true
traditional woman
and wait till you're right not just a
woman not just a virgin a true
traditional woman is a woman that honors
the lord
his aversion waits till marriage they
both get married sanctify each other
and bathe each other with the word
that's a real additional woman yeah and
i i know you know a couple girls that
are like virgins and stuff so i'm not
saying they're impossible but i think
it it's not
easy to find you know a virgin in 2022
for a lot of guys
it depends on what you're looking for
okay
like if you're looking for just a woman
that's just out here in the world
then you know that's a worldly woman
the bible tells you in proverbs not to
date those type of women not to lust i
know but you but you go in the church
and there's like a bunch of girls that
are ran through and burnt born again
virgins like
you can't be born in version sin is sin
yeah but that's what they're they're
preaching
but the thing is they don't
you can preach something but if you're
not living that lifestyle you're a liar
okay
well i don't really think we disagree on
too much so i'm gonna take the next
caller but thank you for calling in have
a good one you did
okay so i'm like
let's see
um
where are we at
hello
hey how's it going
i'm good how are you
doing all right um
so i'll preface that i do agree with
most things that you say but um i
sometimes disagree with how you present
them
because sometimes i feel like you fall
back on the same like statistics or
points not that i disagree with them
it's just like
some people would see that and be like
oh she's just regurgitating stuff
so i don't know if like
what you would say up to that but that's
just one thing that i notice
that i that i repeat stats i've used
before
like i feel like every s like like not
every but like a lot of videos like
you'll fall back to the same topic
or one
like
the
the wage app
like
i feel like the way you say it isn't
like the most
like
agreeable way to say it and like saying
that it doesn't exist
is like not the best way to represent it
you it would like it would probably be
better to say like it doesn't exist the
way you like because of why you think it
does
and and like i i just feel like a lot of
the same talking points get fallen back
too
and
a lot of people could see that as
repetitive
but
okay but there's nothing you disagree
with
oh so that's called disagree with me
i i will i disagree with like how
you
okay next i'm sorry
look it i said disagree with me not i
agree with everything
okay
okay
oh [ __ ] what do you not have a shirt on
what the
what are you guys doing
what are you guys doing
i don't need no weird [ __ ] going on here
oh my god
oh did he have a sweater on i thought he
didn't have a shirt i just i just next
hello
oh hey sorry yeah hey so uh i just found
you recently i love your material i love
your topics you put a lot of thought
into it i really enjoy your stuff just
let me say that um so i really do agree
with pretty much everything you say but
i will give you uh two things
that um
i i hear the study that comes up the
survey that comes up a lot and i've seen
i've heard a lot of other people talk
about it like in the red film community
and everything that like
80 percent of women are going for like
20
of men and that's like a big one of the
biggest indicators is apparently like a
lot of
lack of intimacy and relationships and
sexless men out there and stuff like
that
and i i could be quoting you your your
thought process all wrong but
uh found on the uh
what was it the
international family studies or
something website that has
that actually has a a survey and a study
that kind of that
really contradicts that i thought it was
pretty interesting
saying that a lot of the reasons for the
lack of relationships and
and um
reduced you know childbearing and
the drop-ins and sexual encounters was
because people are getting married a lot
later they're not getting marriage is
getting kind of abandoned
so a lot of that whole um
and basically it was it was specifically
pointed out how the whole you have the
link
uh i you know what i could pull it on
the screen we could read it together i
mean if it's no information
it's a huge article it's a huge article
it goes really in depth trust me you
just want to like glance it over and
mull it over it's definitely not
something you want to scroll through in
a
in a post game
but uh but you know and and i'm not
saying i agree or disagree with either
point completely but but it wasn't
interesting it was interesting to read
it you know but um yeah it was on the
institute for family studies site
and if i had to find it i couldn't to
save my life
but there is an article that that um has
a has a bunch of research and surveys
and data
basically contradicting that whole 80
and you know and i'm not saying that's
not wrong but it's just an opposing
point of view that you know it was
pretty interesting you might want to
read look into it just that doesn't make
sense because if marriage is getting
pushed later and that's the reason like
wouldn't you think more people would be
waiting until they were married
but people aren't so wouldn't that
what would you mean waiting until they
were married
like like yeah yeah because you're
saying sexist list is going like people
aren't having sex because they rate of
marriage is going um up right people are
not no no they're just waiting longer to
get married because people yes yeah
yeah but i'm saying so are these people
waiting until they're married
no they're not waiting to get married
but
but i did read through the statistics
and and believe it or not um believe it
or not married couples actually on
average this study was saying that on
average married couples have more sex
than us than
single people
so
um so that that kind of makes sense
there i mean unless a lot of guys were
lying which you know
i wouldn't be surprised if we weren't
making up stats
live so
no i mean i'd be in if you have the link
send it to me on instagram because i'll
definitely read it yeah i'll look for it
because it was heavy with a lot of
percentages of stats and stuff like that
and like i said i don't think it's
it's all wrong or all right but it was
just a pretty interesting opposing view
and it had a lot of supporting data it
seemed like so i think it would
definitely be something to look into and
uh
and so oh god the other thing oh oh okay
so i'm a single dad three kids right
and i and
i don't know i don't really
disagree with your point i totally
understand it if you can avoid
performing a relationship with uh
someone with kids do it i totally get it
i advocate for that even though i'm a
single dad
um
but i do like what the other guy was
saying is i do think it's
it's very different and and i listen to
a lot of like some red cool stuff i
guess but i don't really go
men going their own way that's just a
little bit too bitter and jaded
for me
but um
the way family law is set up now
and the way that women seek men
women typically seek men that make more
income than them the average right
so if you enter into a relationship
especially a marriage specifically
um making more money than your partner
right off the bat you're screwed with
family law
right off the bat so i think that for
men especially
it's important to avoid that
i think they stand to lose a lot more if
they go into a marriage with um somebody
that already has kids than than the
average woman i could be wrong that's
just my input
you know no i i do think that men and
women having kids is different so i
agree i do think
a guy with kids is a lot
like i would advise
you know it's like the lesser of no
offense but like two evils
um but like
i do think it's different because the
woman
like it's a sign of pre-selection for
women so we're attracted to it and also
shows that he is responsible especially
if he has like full custody i just think
you know if you don't have to deal with
that drama like why would you
uh yeah it's a i i i have to disagree
agree with you there i don't think that
women actually see that as a plus as
equality and let me tell you why a
little social experiment i was on a
dating app i won't name what it is
um and it was i briefly set it up i was
skimming through and i was sitting and i
was and i didn't in the in the profile i
didn't describe myself as having kids
right i figured there's gonna be another
screen where you select are you a smoker
or are you athletic do you have kids
well that never came up and i put the
app down
and i kind of left it alone and over the
course of like two or three days i got
tons of hits and i was getting all the
pictures and contacted and everything
and i thought oh my god this is really
effective if these people are real
and then i went back and i started
looking at people's profiles and i
realized oh god i didn't put on there
that i was a father so i switched it
over right and i added in my profile
that i had kids immediately
crickets
like
the next four or five days i heard
nothing unless you were an absolute
train wreck so i i don't think women
actually seek that out as like a
as a plus well this is this is what i
mean by that like if a girl watches a
man
interact with kids it's like attractive
to us it's like ah because it kind of
it's that biological need you know and i
don't think it's the same for men
yeah i know was it yeah yeah
so on some level we're attracted to it
but
we could still be logical and be like
you know what no maybe that's not
yeah yeah but um i'll look for that
article and i'll find a way to get it to
you it was it was heavy with data so
it's definitely yeah
right now but but anyway i want to eat
up all the time love your show super
good points really intelligent
conversations i hear on your show so
really like it
okay thanks for calling in yeah no
problem
okay um i'm gonna go another like
10 minutes 15.
um
okay
one dude is driving we talked about
driving
are you the man that didn't have a shirt
on oh he's got a shirt now
oh wow that's crazy
yeah i didn't
as a guy i never thought in my life that
i actually get exposure so my bad sorry
about that i apologize extremely
okay what's going on what do you
disagree with me on um i had to think
about this
but as um so recently not recently but
i'm 20 years old i have a six-year-old
sister now
hey i'm i'm not sweating yes i was 20
years old and then i got a six i got a
sister at 20 years old so i'm 26 now
anyways though i've been thinking about
it like dang i'm like what am also teach
her
you know so i've been sitting back
trying to figure her out
i guess the idea of the disagreement is
that
i think i'm feeling bad for for a woman
in general
that they have a lot of options
and it's hard for them to flex that
options
but at a very
minimal amount of you know like it's
it's like usually a virgin that's zero
you know
or even if it's not zero then it's like
five right you know but that's still a
very little amount of people
and i'm like yo that's
that could be hard
back in the day maybe it wasn't but now
is it is it hard i don't know
i'm very confused i'm very very confused
and i care the reason i'm thinking about
it because i care
and then like you know
it's even another topic i guess because
you know about the what just happened
over roe v wade and then somebody asked
me she was like oh what do you feel
about about that case and i told her
straight up was like i was told on
social media many many times to not care
about i have no opinion as a guy who
have opinion on a willing body so i told
her shut up
i have no opinion and you know
you're an [ __ ] you should have a pain
like you didn't want me to have an
opinion before but now you owe me
opinions
okay what do you disagree with me on day
and night yeah exactly to talk about you
wanted to go on to what you were trying
to say is that um
how do you feel i i feel bad for a lot
of women that have a lot of options
to not how do you feel about
i i'm not not disagreeing but i would
say how do you feel about them not
exercising those options there's a lot
of options i actually got to think about
how to sit back and like yo there's a
lot of options
how do i feel about girls not exercising
their options
yeah i feel like i feel like there's a
lot as in as in waiting until they're
married to have sex
yeah because you are i mean after
after one fine i think if
if you're at zero then then yeah you
never you don't know what you're getting
yourself into but after one then how do
you
so so how do i feel about women having
sex
after they're not a virgin anymore
yeah let's go with that
the options at that point is very
it's high i'm not like you know often
they are their officers are
that they they have a lot of people they
can sleep with
yes
they do
i just don't know what you're asking me
oh my bad i'm not really asking the
question i guess and i'm trying more
saying that um
that i understand that idea of us guys
saying that we sh we want to have a
woman with low body count okay but then
now i'm kind of understanding like yo
it's actually very accessible for them
i'm actually like i don't remind you i'm
a guy i don't know the logic of the idea
of
not going for something i'm a guy i
would go for something okay
well i think i think there's there's two
ends right this is what i'm hearing from
the men and the women the women are
frustrated because they feel like men
have unrealistic standards for 2022
and they feel like um
basically that the body counts that men
are saying are too
too low and that's not realistic and
from the men i'm hearing i'm really sick
of having these ran through girls right
um
i don't i think that women should try to
keep their body count as low as possible
and be very selective with who they
sleep with that's my opinion on it i
think if you can wait till marriage i
think that's the best way to do it
um but
obviously like i didn't do that so i'm
not gonna
so
yeah
so
i think that that's like my opinion on
it
but i don't know how much we disagree
like i'm not a girl i'm not i'm not for
i'm not four girls just like sleeping
with all their options like i don't
think that's no i had to apologize i
called it and then i had my shirt off
and i wasn't expecting yeah it's okay
i'm gonna move on to the next person
though but thank you for calling and
appreciate it
okay
so
yeah okay um
let's see
uh are you driving
what are you looking i'm gonna pull over
i'm gonna pull over i don't pull over i
don't pull over don't worry
it's like i say i say
don't drive
and then
we're driving it's like
hello
okay
um
are you dry
yo
freaking
wow
hey
oh i need you to be on camera hold on
hold on hold on
can you hear me now
yeah i can hear you what's up
hey so i was just in conflict with one
of your i guess your points and your
earlier shows i think it had to do with
um
marriage and children
okay let's go
do you think you should be married to
have children
yes
um it doesn't have to be legally with
the government
so i get okay so that's where i was
coming in conflict is because
you said men should typically not try to
get married you throw a lot of
statistics i get it
but then having kids
marriage how does that tie into play
because
well i just think marriage is the best
for families
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
with the government um there's
you know you can do that in your church
but i do think a lifelong commitment is
important for building families
right so
i guess any legalness with being married
shouldn't if you want if a man wants to
have children
he doesn't you say that it's okay
be a lifelock committed partner but
don't you don't have to involve the
state or anything to leave see
see this is this is where i'm kind of
torn on this issue that's right because
after after i
i listened to the laws
on just how men get screwed in with
child support
because i i don't understand why these
girls need child support we can get jobs
we can work so i i don't really get this
but
at the same time i i really do believe
in marriage like my parents are married
i think it was good for our family but i
would understand a guy not wanting to
get married so i think that like for a
family there has to be like some sort of
you know and maybe it's not with the
government like i've heard people kind
of trying to go around that or maybe a
prenup is the answer but
i i do think marriage is the best for
families
um
so i i agree yes i was like if i ever
want to get have children i would want
to get married but
the thing is like well a lot of you know
shows and podcasts they say you know
bears shouldn't be for men or men it's
not really a good deal and such i mean
if i know what i'm getting into i mean i
i choose it and there's always a risk no
matter what
but my guess for me
for men to get married is to have
children even though
the woman can take the children i
understand that i know all that but
also
like i still wanted to for the child
it's more secure for them it's purely
for the child like secure let's raise
the child make them successful and then
afterwards you know then y'all do
whatever but
legally i'm just i'm torn to say like
be married brian or be married to
you know if you want children but then
they say oh also don't get married
because
there's a lot of reasons that as a man
the
marriage is not really a good
thing to follow through with
so
and i just wanted your i guess if you
had a resolution for me for that that
paradox in my head no but i should do a
show on that the resolution going
forward you guys are giving me good show
ideas
in your interviews i saw your little
thoughts thing earlier i'm sorry oh
thanks no it's okay nothing nothing
really happened like i just had i was
just like oh god i gotta get out of here
so
like it's still a nervous feeling i
guess yeah
but
but thank you for calling in appreciate
it no problem i have
um okay
oh no
okay guys it's been an hour
um i
i'm going to bed i'm sorry y'all
i'm sorry y'all
tired
but
it's 3 30 in the morning here in london
so
we you're ending the stream
well i didn't get any women tonight well
i did but the wi-fi was bad
so tell your tell your
females about these shows send me your
feminists
okay i should have come with the topic
maybe i will next time sometimes i just
be thinking
anyways guys i love you
talk to you later bye